hello guys and welcome to another video
in this video we're going to be
discussing another leak which comes from
some reliable scoopers and this is
regarding that sony apparently wants
emma stone for a spider gwen project now
this is referring to the gwen which was
bit by radioactive spider and her peter
parker died in a universe which was
explained in into the spider-verse film
which quickly spider gwen did become a
fan favorite and people have actually
been wanting to see her in a live-action
project so this news is quite exciting
and what makes it even more exciting is
that there are rumors that i want andrew
garfield to share the screen with
spider-gwen now this will be emma stone
and andrew garfield reuniting in a
spider-man film as we do know um her
character an amazing spider-man 2 died
so andrew garfield spiderman seeing her
again would be a very emotional scene
potentially we could see the scene from
the comics where spider-grin and
spider-man see each other and they both
explained where spider-man says i
couldn't save gwen stacey of my world
and then gwen says i couldn't save the
peter parker and mine so then they'd
make a deal where they would look over
each other so this would be a pretty
emotional scene and i hope we get to see
it anyway guys that's about it for this
video a bit of a shorter one but pretty
exciting nevertheless and also guys
remember just to take this with a grain
of salt it is a rumor but if it does
turn out to be true what would you like
to see from a spider-gwen movie let me
know in the comment section below and if
you did enjoy the video please like and
subscribe and turn notifications on to
show your support thanks for watching
guys